con los casos de kobe de 19 en aumento
el consejo científico de francia ha
hecho nuevas recomendaciones destinadas
a frenar la quinta ola de contagios
primero endurecer las reglas sobre el
uso de mascarillas particularmente en
espacios cerrados donde se requiere el
pase sanitario en este restaurante
parisino pocas personas usan sus
máscaras para desplazarse dentro del
lugar hacerlo nuevamente obligatorio
podría no ser tan sencillo como todo el
mundo está vacunado estamos en un
entorno sano y protegido tener que usar
una mascarilla sería una obligación de
más para el dueño del restaurante no
sería el fin del mundo
si fue si es necesario lo haremos
cualquier cosa para evitar otro cierre u
otro toque de queda el uso de
mascarillas al aire libre se ha vuelto
obligatorio en varias regiones otra
recomendación del consejo científico
trabajar más desde casa una opción de
momento descartada por el gobierno
aunque los científicos afirman su
eficacia para mantener el virus bajo
control
sabemos que reducir el traslado de
personas limitar a la interacción lo que
por lo tanto bajará la propagación del
virus rivers la oficina del primer
ministro apoyaría a reinstaurar los
límites máximos de personas en espacios
cerrados el consejo científico también
propuso pruebas de covite generalizadas
en las escuelas a la primera señal de un
caso positivo las recomendaciones surgen
luego de que francia registrará un
aumento del 82 por ciento en nuevas
infecciones la semana pasada con un
promedio de 18 mil 500 nuevos casos por
día el propio primer ministro francés
yann castex dio positivo por 19 lunes
después de reunirse con su homólogo
belga alexander de croo en bruselas
castex está completamente vacunado y
seguirá trabajando desde casa de forma
aislada